given all the noise that i was talking
yesterday yeah about all we got to do is
get it to 2-2 2-2
i'm actually disappointed that i get i
didn't get that text that's what i was i
was actually waiting for i looked at my
phone i'm like hey maybe the old man's
asleep i thought i was gonna get it so
you know i i was fully expecting you to
uh
to gloat to start the show
and take it i just rather join the
family
i gotta do it in front of the family
here look man like come on you had to
know you had to know when lebron james
got off that bus before he even knew
about the text message that he sent to
his teammates and the text message on
the group on the group chain was simply
must win
in text must win definitely before he
even knew about that before you knew
about that
when my man got off the bus wearing the
kobe bryant
t-shirt i think you knew you were in
trouble then right
is that what you know listen
listen hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on let's let's let's be accurate
about this okay cuz i just wanted to
make sure i had this right
305 left in the game i'll tell you
exactly my viewing experience 305 left
in the game
all right
yep jimmy butler had i believe a corner
three
and my wife can tell you i'm watching
the game in bed i'm like come on jimmy
it's 90 to 88
it's 90 to 88 so you can talk about how
lebron showed up to the game
right and he looked great and i know he
meant business and his text message
which i definitely want to get into his
text message suggested that he met
business last night
right but it was 1988 and jimmy butler
had a wide open three
that he missed i said come on jimmy and
he missed i'm like damn they needed that
at the other end the ensuing possession
kentavious caldwell pope
it's a three-pointer say that and now
it's 93-88 i'm like ah damn say that
again
so that's what i'm saying
the heat did not get beat by lebron and
anthony davis last night they got beat
by kentavious caldwell pope 15 points
outscoring the entire heat bench that
was the game that was the game right
there that was a story of course it was
a game and this is why i want to
continue to talk trash to you because
that's what i told you i told you you
wouldn't listen i told you about the la
lakers this is not a team that is just
all about anthony davis and lebron james
there are some forgotten lakers i got it
there somewhere lakers leafy god you see
like you know i had it written down the
lake we forgot get the bottom oh neither
one you can't stop it stop it if you
don't this you didn't forget about them
no we know they played for the lakers no
you where did you ask them okay that's
better that's more accurate that's more
accurate yeah okay all right
i dismissed him i disrespected him yes
you're right let me rewrite that in real
time the lakers
ms dismissed
okay michael smith's dismissed that's
more like it yeah i knew about him just
because this team but this has happened
the entire series and it's funny how we
do this and we do this in all sports so
in the nba finals it really has come
down to the the miami storyline is
they've been overlooked they got jimmy
butler who's a superstar tyler tyler
heroes emerging superstar eric spoelstra
is the best coach in the league pat
riley great team builder okay that's
that's the miami story in a nutshell
right did i get to all the major things
remind me the lakers hey lebron about to
win his third championship uh with with
another team anthony davis finally in
the finals the lakers about to tie the
celtics for all-time finals all the
stuff
did the lakers build themselves do they
coach themselves i haven't heard much
about frank vogel i mean i i take eric
spoelstra over frank vogel but frank
vogel is a very good coach
he's got some washed up sorry coach
who's along for the ride and how about
their general manager i remember magic
johnson
going on tv just ripping him up and down
i had to leave because of rob palinka oh
rob wanted my job which may be true
but rob polinka has done a pretty good
job and i remember when they got lebron
and some of these
complimentary players were brought
aboard
and people were saying well why are they
doing this why are they bringing in
rajon rondo
what why did can tabias caldwell pope
what's he going to do
what what what are they doing this is
not going to work it has worked the
lakers that either we forgot or michael
smith dismissed or one went away
one went away and i don't care what time
i'm texting you constantly i'm going to
ask my
i'll be on silent mode i'll be on friday
night on sleep mode whatever the mode is
that you put on your phone will be yours
you can text me text away that doesn't
mean i'm an answer here's the other
thing
that's fine i'll tell you something
about some other things to do on our
friday night than text you go ahead i'm
listening
this is this is yours i mentioned this
is your time cook cook go ahead i was
going to mention that
since and i was saying this to uh my
beautiful wife earlier today i said you
know what i miss you know what i miss
i miss date night
i miss going out
date night without the uh without the
mask and the social i'm just talking
about just going out just having a good
time out of character the chatter of
other people the music playing you know
all this stuff
and so since i don't have date nights
anymore or friday nights what i'm going
to do is just text you and just harass
you okay i'm good i'm going to make you
i'm going to take out my frustrations on
you on friday night when the lakers
clinch i got you no listen i i i'm
enjoying this actually because i was
prepared for it and i had it coming um
i'm enjoying this because i know you're
not a wrestling guy
well you're not a boston guy i know
you're not a boston guy but you are
associated with boston boston has been
your home for most of your adult life
and i would venture to say that in the
history of boston sports
never has anybody in boston been this
enthusiastic about a lakers championship
so this is actually rather entertaining
for me
this is really the whole reason
yeah the whole region is sick the whole
region is free
except for you except for you because
you are because i think you are military
so get ready get ready i've seen this
before okay um when phil jackson won
let's see it must have been in 2000 when
they beat when they beat the pacers
so i think that was title number 10
for phil jackson i could be a mistake it
may be somewhere in there oh yeah yeah
but
when he when he won the title that that
got him past red our back
man
you want to hear some hate
you want to talk about hating hating
hating hating oh man you have never
heard so much hate celtics fans are
about to be salty well yeah fans i'm i'm
sure they go outside of asterisk next to
this anyway yeah like
watching the championship
nobody you beat the fifth seed you know
whatever even though they lost to set
fifth seed but no actually um you gotta
admit this though man jack just just at
least give me this
number one you've already crowned the
king in the lakers understandably so
um you've already crowned him it's 3-1
lebron's 3-0 with an opportunity to
clinch when he smells blood he closes
all right
um
you got it you the heat made you sweat
like think about like when we had mark
spears and gary washburn
on the show yesterday i thought mark
spears dropped an unintentional clever
lead he was like the lakers are playing
with fire messing around giving the heat
confidence i'm like yeah that's good and
you gotta admit yeah the the heat have
it's 3-1
but it's been an entertaining 3-1
game one not withstand it's been for the
most part entertaining 3-1 and the heat
have made the lakers sweat and i'm not
so sure this doesn't still go six i
think you picked the lakers in five uh
you may ultimately be right with your
pick of the lakers championship
meanwhile i picked the heat in six not
looking so good
the heat ain't gonna show up and roll
over i think you know that so let's try
another one of those locked in games
from lebron james
uh to close this thing out and to kill
jimmy butler in the heat would you mind
if i transition to lebron because i do
want to love all lebron go ahead
go ahead go ahead transition to lebron
but before you do that transition i just
want to i want to give credit where it's
due though i believe and if one of them
will say all right
you got it wrong but i believe it was
chris haynes
who said they'll win in five but it's
going to be like oklahoma city
versus miami where it was that that kind
of five game series where where the
games were close but ultimately they
went in five and so uh i'll give credit
i think it was chris haynes or vinnie
goodwill one of them said it right and i
think uh they're absolutely right close
here you're right it's been entertaining
let's talk let's talk lebron um
and let's let's play what he said after
the game that that must win text that he
sent to his team group chat
um
when i woke up from my nap
[Music]
this morning after our team meeting i
just i just felt that
i felt that vibe i felt that
i felt that pressure
i felt like for me personally this was
one of the biggest games in my career
and um
just wanted to relay that message to my
teammates what type of zone i was in
type of moment it was
because i just know how great of a team
that we're playing against
and after the game three um win that
confidence that they had they still have
even after tonight's loss
um
just a
gritty so damn well coached team
but i feel like
if we want to be a championship ball
club if we really want to be a
championship team that we
we got we got to have that same grit and
that same attitude so
i'm just
it's just my mindset kind of still in it
obviously
it's my mind kind of working right now
and i love it i absolutely i don't know
if he's getting better at this or i'm
just more locked in or in tune into what
he's saying i love listening to lebron
his lessons on leadership now more than
ever we heard a glimpse of that in the
western conference finals uh when he
talked about having to match denver's
desperation and and adopting their
mindset like we can't lose this game you
know i want to end this series tonight
uh in that closeout game and and the
mindset a couple of things about his
mindset jumped out to me so i got a
couple takeaways from that one is i
laugh
you know at the people who over the
years have talked about lebron's lack of
a killer instinct or lebron not being
clutch there's something clutch
to come update those files right right
they got to update they got to update
them files well but think about like you
know that finite definition of clutch
we've evolved from one shot
and we've gotten to the last five
minutes of the game score within five
points or we've even gotten to hey a big
game to stave off elimination or game
seven performance overall which lebron
has plenty of big game performances but
sometimes it's a near triple double with
six turnovers
you know sometimes it's the mindset that
you go into it as a leader and say hey
i know what's at stake here and if like
michael smith said
we fully write and let the heat get to
2-2
this series could turn so there's
something about
seeing a situation and knowing like yo
i'ma squash this comeback before it even
gets started you know there's a saying
in sports
uh that that good teams don't win close
games they avoid them you know like
sometimes killers
don't get into situations where they
gotta rescue their team sometimes you
know superheroes say you know what let
me avoid a situation altogether get us
to 3-1 where we got opportunity to close
this out and not fool around with this
team i got a second take away but i'll
pass it to you i don't i don't want
pound to rock too much i got a second
take away from that uh that comment from
lebron go ahead
yeah i want to hear your second takeaway
but before we hear it i do want to
kind of jump on to that leadership pile
and that's the thing that impresses me
the most about lebron james he is a
leader and i think i told you this story
before he has been a leader
since he was in high school
way back wait long long long time ago i
had to do a story
for the chicago tribune how about that
old school uh two thousand one of you
one of your one of your five stories
from the chicago tribunal
you had less than two years less than a
cup of coffee in chicago 29
29
29 that's the shortest chapter of your
career story and about half of them half
of them on the bears
shout out jim miller shane matt shane
matthews and quarterback anyway um
so but one of the stories i did for the
chicago tribune was on a 16 year old
lebron james
and what stood out to me more than
anything was how his teammates came to
him not to the coaching staff but came
to him and asked him hey how how are we
supposed to run this play
well why isn't this play running the way
it is supposed to
and at that time he was still playing
high school football he was a all-state
wide receiver imagine lebron james
coming down the seam no thank you i
could say okay
all right but he was an allstate wide
receiver so they had a playoff game that
night he wasn't there at the first half
of practice but the second half of
practice he came in and the energy level
picked up everybody was communicating
you can just feel the collective iq of
the room rise so he has been a leader
since he was 16 and his leadership now
just jumps out at me that's why
i was confident that they were going to
win this series not just because they're
the more talented team and they are but
a leader can
tell somebody to do something they don't
necessarily want to do or a leader can
make you see something
that
that you didn't see it before i'm making
you see it i'm making you feel something
that you didn't feel before i think he's
very good at that pass back to you
michael smith bounce pass yeah i mean
just to have a must-win-win mentality
when as you know you know must win is is
thrown around too loosely you know
because you must well if you lose
then you still got a chance tomorrow so
it's not really a must win you know what
i mean so that's why we can't use that
uh too liberally but here's lebron james
adopting that mindset calling it one of
the biggest games of his career somebody
who's got so little left to accomplish
nothing left to prove
adopting the mindset that this is the
biggest one this is the biggest game of
my career like being in the moment like
that is is really powerful and it's such
a privilege to watch him lead and
actually what you said you're getting me
the ball right in my spot because that's
what i wanted to get into we've all
killed a lot of times
or some people actually you know use it
as an insult is that lebron you know
thinks he's the coach or that or that
he's a difficult person to coach i
reject that i think that makes him i
would imagine a pleasure to coach or if
nothing else a privilege to coach
because he you know keeps the actual
coaches accountable and we know a coach
on the floor
but
and not to get too far ahead of
ourselves but that's what i do here
go ahead he's nowhere close to retiring
i'm not trying to put him out to pasture
he looks like he could do this for
another five years at minimum
but
listening to him lead is such a such a a
treat and listen to how he communicates
bro you know what i would love to see
him do in his next chapter
i mean i know he's got business ventures
and entertainment goals and a family to
continue raising and you know and
philanthropy and i promise school i know
he's got a lot
man i would love to see him try coaching
and i would love to see how many rings
he can win as a coach in fact i would
love to see if he could be the next
jerry west
i mean could he be could he be
somebody who excels as an executive
people want to talk about the
comparisons to michael jordan we know mj
has not gotten it done as an executive
i would love to see lebron or not
yes let's just say the least that's a
nice that's just a nice very important
i would love to see lebron james
make a run at a handful of rings as a
coach or as an architect could he be pat
riley you know could he take all the
lessons he's learned over the years
and because you know how a lot of great
players have a difficult time
transitioning into coaching because
right obviously the players can't meet
their standard he's the type of guy that
i think could could get that out of
every player from the best player to the
12th player
all right and real quick because i know
we got some other stuff we want to get
to but real quick on that uh you said
two things let me just
uh highlight those one
lebron with coaching and like how he's
got that mind he's got that memory just
like the other day we talked about it
remember he was talking about dallas oh
yeah it was game two dwyane wade hit a
shot in front of their bench and then we
thought we were going to win the series
and and they came back and they won the
game won one series so he just remembers
these little things but
uh mike brown
uh his his coach for five years in
cleveland told me a great story about
lebron he said you know
you would have to he said i would i need
to come into that meeting and have to be
on point
because lebron would notice every little
thing
and if i got one thing wrong he's gonna
point it out
and so i needed it made me a better
coach and made me
pay more attention to detail
because i needed to i needed to stay
sharp with this guy so i agree with you
mike it's not necessarily a negative
it takes you to another level if you
approach it in that way now if you're an
insecure person
okay it's gonna be a problem for you
because it's not just about
lebron james challenging you you got
deeper issues that are that are far
beyond a player saying yeah right he
makes you he takes to a different level
it makes you better i i just imagine a
whole different goat conversation
where it's like we've already talked
about how he's distinguished himself
from jordan or kareem and the path that
he's forged imagine a whole different
goat conversation if he becomes maybe
the most successful or decorated figure
not just player but figure in nba
history if he could add a fist full of
rings you know as a coach as an
executive as a team builder whatever it
is i just hope he's still
imparting these gems this free jewelry
that he's giving out i hope he's still
doing that well after he i like it